c'est notre panel politique avec nos
deux chefs de bureaux d2 collins est pas
si mauvais au québec madeleine blé
maurey qui était au froid pour sera vous
deux au saut du lit
mais c'est incontournable de parler de
vaccins se termine bien et semaine en
réalité parce que ce sont de bonnes
nouvelles dont quatrième vaccins
approuvés dans l'arsenal canadien contre
lacko vide avec ce vaccin est une dose
seulement de johnson & johnson
ça va s'accélérer les livraisons aussi
du côté de pfizer
alors tout ça ça va bien sébastien on
s'appelle de monsieur du bilan qui avait
apporté l'espèce d'analogie l'aluminé sa
santé d'une voiture de course qui avait
pas descendre mon vélo l'essence arrive
on est en train de remplir le réservoir
de la voiture
voilà puis là ça va prendre un
conducteur dans le dos puis quelqu'un
qui sait comment comptes tu es poussé
comment vacciner parce que on aura les
libre à des québécois vont être prêts à
se faire vacciner la question c'est de
savoir ce qu'on aura assez de bras pour
vacciner pile l'ambition en fait il
le gouvernement du québec a pas vraiment
eu le choix de vacciner des centaines de
milliers de personnes par semaine à
partir du moment où les vaccins vont
rentrer par centaines de milliers de
doses par semaine parce que le fardeau
du succès de la vaccination va retomber
sur ses épaules la job de justin trudeau
ces deux livres et d'approvisionner les
vaccins dans les provinces puis les
provinces leur job c'est de vacciner
alors il a besoin de tout son monde
c'est pas pour rien qui réquisitionne
les pharmaciens c'est pas pour rien que
il demande à des gens sur je contribue
de lever la main des vétérinaires des
sages-femmes des physiothérapeutes et
qu'il demande vous en avait parlé en
début de bulletins avec valérie il
demande aussi au milieu des affaires de
se mobiliser pour pouvoir vacciner le
plus de monde possible à passer là bas
il a placé la barre au monde avec son
idée est assez frappant là un million de
personnes vaccinées par semaine au début
de juin
c'est presque un fantasme un million
parce que l'inde quand on additionne de
nos quatre cent mille personnes par les
infirmières du réseau public
deux cent mille par le milieu des
affaires 200 milles par les pharmaciens
chaque semaine on est hors du coup à 800
milles
on se rapproche du million mais pour
arriver à un million va falloir vraiment
pressé le citron au maximum maintenant
la job comme vous avez dit gouvernement
fédéral sébastien si je reprends vos
termes ici c'est de s'assurer que les
livraisons s'achemine alors madeleine ça
semble être le cas
ça remet le gouvernement trudeau dans
une position un peu plus confortable je
dirais j'ai l'impression que la semaine
a beaucoup changé la dynamique du côté
fédéral parce que bon on eu ce vaccin là
aujourd'hui autorisé de johnson &
johnson
mais un peu plus tôt cette semaine il y
avait cette recommandation qui
permettait maintenant d'étendre la
période l'intervalle entre deux doses à
quatre mois donc ça ça aide aussi la
vaccination d'une plus grande proportion
de la population plus rapidement il y
avait aussi le fait que les états unis
devraient avoir fini de vacciner la
population adulte fin mai donc et puis
il est possible qu'on va avoir accès à
des vaccins provenant des états unis ça
aussi ça pourrait faciliter la dynamique
l'arrivée des vaccins d'astrazeneca
première livraison cette semaine donc je
vous dirais leur côté vaccination
c'était une bonne semaine puis moi je
connais rien aux voitures le magicien
trouver une image aussi pour savoir quel
genre de voiture les inoublis et
provinces vont avoir besoin pour
vacciner aussi rapidement toute la
population puis je me suis dit il
faudrait comme jean de dollars real dans
le retour vers le futur avec l'énergie
nucléaire parce que là le défi va être
logistique le défi va être véritablement
du côté des provinces et c'est peut-être
un peu pour ça que le gouvernement
trudeau doit aussi se garder une petite
gêne pour ne pas promettre formellement
d'être en mesure d'avoir vacciner tous
les canadiens avant la cible de
septembre c'est sûr qu'ils ont aussi
tout le fait qu'on n'est jamais à l'abri
d'autres problèmes de livraison ou de
retard chez les manufacturiers
mais le défi logistique du côté des
provinces et pas juste québec le toutes
les provinces
ça va être quand même assez difficile
qui est venue quand même un petit peu à
s'ouvrir la semaine de justin trudeau ce
sur tous ces rebondissements dans l'
enquête en cours sur les allégations
d'inconduite sexuelle concernant
l'ancien grand patron général-vincent de
l'ancien grand patron des forces
canadiennes alors on a de plus en plus
d'informations comme quoi le ministre de
la défense monsieur stade je le savais
depuis déjà trois ans là il ya d'autres
informations comme quoi
du côté du bureau du conseil privé donc
on se rapproche du premier ministre hugo
on le savait là aussi qu'est ce que ça
veut dire qu'est ce que ça comme impact
parce que monsieur trudeau lui il n'y
qui savait quoi que ce soit d'ailleurs
petit extrait monsieur trudeau
dis ce que je dis encore jeune je ne je
n'ai été mise au courant des allégations
contre les général vance que par le
travail des journalistes à globo nous
sommes en train de faire une enquête
approfondie pour avoir tous les faits la
madame la question est qu'est ce qu'on
doit comprendre de tout seul il manque
des gros bouts à l'histoire moi je
comparerais ça un fromage suisse lors il
ya des trous là dedans et les gros trous
je dirais que ce sont les c'est le
ministre de la défense pardon qui les a
creusé par exemple cette semaine lorsque
l'ancien ombudsman des forces armées
venues témoigner en disant j'ai voulu
alerter le ministre il ya pas voulu
regarder les allégations à ce moment là
le ministre a publié une déclaration en
disant je suis pas d'accord avec
certaines parties du témoignage mais le
pot dit lesquels plus tard dans sa
déclaration il dit lorsque le réseau
global a publié des informations des
allégations au sujet de jonathan devance
l'ancien chef d'état major de la défense
j'ai été surpris comme tout le monde ah
oui alors pourquoi on apprend qu'il
était au courant il ya 3 ans du fait
qu'il y avait des allégations et il le
dit dans la même déclaration
et lorsque j'ai été mise au courant j'ai
laisé apple acheminés à des autorités
compétentes c'est difficile de
réconcilier tout ça c'est difficile
d'être à la fois surpris et d'avoir
référer aux autorités compétentes
donc il ya encore de gros points
d'interrogation sur la déclaration du
ministre sajjad et au delà du monde
politique julie toute cette affaire la
vieille vraiment compliqué la réforme
qui est nécessaire au sein des forces
armées canadiennes pour essayer
d'enrayer toute les inconduites sexuelle
il y avait la juge deschamps qui avait
mené une enquête à l'époque il ya cinq
ans là tuez-le disais il faut que toute
cette réforme là soit dirigée par les
piliers du 2 du monde militaire et les
piliers du monde militaire c'est
peut-être jonathan de vente ci est sous
enquête son successeur est sous enquête
et le ministre s'adjoignent des
questions au sujet de ce qu'ils savaient
ce qu'ils ne savaient pas et surtout de
sa réaction par les incursions de même
le mécanisme
on se demande pourquoi ça s'est
tellement confus qui parle à quoi
pourquoi lui parle de 100 à tel autre
absolument et ça bien ça fait partie du
problème c'est des gens veulent porter
plainte si on veut les encourager à
porter plainte
faut savoir où aller et je dirais que
cette semaine sa démontré qu' il ya
probablement beaucoup de monde qui ne
savaient pas à qui s'adresser et madame
des champs supérieurs dans son rapport a
recommandé de sortir le processus de
plainte des défenseurs mais pour donner
à l'extérieur pour rajouter un trou dans
le fromage suisse justin trudeau à mi
temps on a rajouté un aujourd'hui nous
sommes les informations que l'homme
bodemann nous est transmise au conseil
privé était pas suffisante pour aller
plus loin mais excusez moi mais à partir
du moment où on dit allégations puis
chef de l'état-major dans la même france
on doit on doit on doit pousser plus
loin en tout cas ça s'est su exactement
principe ya une alarme qui sonne qui ont
même si les informations qu'on reçoit
sont pas concluantes
on pose peut-être un peu plus loin ça
s'appelle la responsabilité
l'imputabilité
alors ça c'était l'aspect un peu plus
semble de la semaine de justin trudeau
parlons maintenant parce qu'il sent bien
du côté du parti conservateur parce
qu'ils vont tenir une convention c'est
bientôt ses 18 au 20 mars mais ce qu'on
apprenait aujourd'hui en raison entre
autres global mais on sait qu'il ya des
militants pro-avortement il aimerait
très présent et j'aimerais avoir un bon
nombre de délégués on a l'impression
qu'il ya tout un jeu de pression qui va
jouer lors de cette convention là et
c'est risqué pour monsieur autour
madeleine oui c'est sûr que ce groupe le
groupe pro-vie le groupe anti avortement
et c'est souvent de prendre la place au
sein du parti et très organisé et fait
beaucoup de bruit c'est ce qu'on dit
vous sein du parti et que ultime ans ça
veut pas dire qu'ils vont réussir à
faire adopter des résolutions parce que
c'est très très très compliqué de monter
la colline là jusqu'à l'adoption de
résolutions il faut avoir des majorités
qu'on appelle double des majorités parmi
tous les délégués parmi toutes les
provinces
donc ça devient compliqué mais pour
monsieur autour il s'est quand même un
test de de montrer démontrer qui est
capable de garder son parti uni et
démontrer pas juste aux panneaux au
membre du parti mais à l'ensemble des
canadiens
qu'ils s'adressent aussi à eux qu'il est
capable d'élargir la tante conservatrice
comme il avait dit qu'il veut
qu'ils le feraient à lorsqu'il est
devenu chef du parti conservateur
donc ce sera un test pour lui bien
évidemment dans le congrès politique
même s'il n'y a pas de résolution anti
avortement qui sont adoptées lors de ce
congrès la et combien ce parti-là s'est
passé du côté jusqu'ici moi je vous
interromps plus vous lisant quelque
chose et le petit moss et lily combat
gens sont toujours boiteuse parfois
besoin peuvent être boiteuse mais ça me
fait penser un peu au parti québécois
une certaine époque qui sont entre
déchirés sur la place publique certains
courants qui tirait la couverture d'un
autre côté pis le chef qui essayait de
ramener ça pour ramener tout le monde
sous le même parapluie
monsieur otto lille a dégonflé la
balloune de ces conservateurs
conservateur en étant nommé en disant
nous sommes pragmatiques nous sommes
modérée nous sommes dans le court le
courant dominant donc il veut et il
essaie de s'en défaire mais c'est comme
s'ils ont toujours en train de vendre un
peu son mollet pour essayer de ramener
contraire et contrairement à un joshi
lui il est beaucoup plus claire sur la
question de l'avortement il veut laisser
le libre choix
ça c'est clair mais lors de sa course à
la direction du parti
il vous flirtez quand même un petit peu
avec les groupes anti-avortement pour
essayer de se hisser jusqu'à la tête du
parti jusque pour obtenir le leadership
du parti donc c'est peut-être un peu
normal qu'il ya une frange un groupe
dans le parti qui lui en veux un petit
peu long il a quand même surpris
sébastien le parti conservateur a
surpris parce que finalement ils sont
éloignés de cet engagement qu'ils
avaient par le passé là sur une
déclaration d'impôt unique pour le
québec a tout à coup là ils en veulent
plus
ils ont voté en faveur du début du
projet nous allons voter contre des
articles pour enclencher le processus
on sait plus trop sur quel pied danser
no more duc et dimitri soudas ce qui a
encore des bons contacts ou parti
conservateur nous dit que le parti
conservateur est toujours en faveur de
la déclaration de revenu unique mais on
l'a pas entendu à un autre nom de la
bouche des renault tout ce qui ajoute au
brouillard
non seulement ça mais monsieur otto dix
on a d'autres priorités envers le québec
que celle là alors en effet
monsieur o'toole avait pris cette fois
on avait l'impression que le parti
conservateur s'en aller dans cette
direction là peut-être pour séduire un
peu la revendication du québec parce
qu'une motion unanime à l'assemblée
nationale qui avec la russa est ce qu'il
va être capable de remettre la pâte à
dents dans un tube et puis passer à
autre chose
donc il est traîné un petit boulet cette
semaine sur cette question et puis la
dernière chose que je voulais aborder
avec vous c'est un peu une surprise
aujourd'hui on apprend que la conjointe
du blogueur qui est emprisonné depuis
des années on a l'habitude vous
hésiterez oui donc sa conjointe en sa
faveur qui songe à se présenter pour le
bloc québécois s'est passé avez vous été
aussi surpris que moi oui plutôt
je connaissais pas les l'idéologie
politique de cette dame on sait qu'elle
est on l'a beaucoup vu puis on aime
beaucoup parce qu'elle est très
revendicatrice évidemment pour monsieur
badaoui et elle a su charmer une bonne
partie des québécois pour prendre parti
pour monsieur badaoui c'est délicat
l'arabie saoudite le gouvernement est
toujours avec une patate chaude quand il
est question de l'arabie saoudite c'est
peut-être normal que se retrouve au bloc
québécois réaction madeleine et le bloc
québécois avaient fait adopter une
motion à la chambre des communes pour
demander que son mari obtiennent la
citoyenneté canadienne
donc il ya je pense qu'elle se retrouve
aussi au sein du bloc québécois pour ça
pour la combativité du bloc à sa cause à
elle à la cause de son mari
il faut encore qu'il passe une assemblée
d'investiture potentiellement là le
comté est pas nécessairement libre pour
elle parce que je manquais très
dangereux sa maîtrise du français aussi
mais elle parle mieux le français
qu'elle a déjà parlé donc elle démontre
quand même son attachement au québec
en voulant se lancer pour le bloc
québécois on verra bien ce que les
électeurs vont tous merci beaucoup pour
ce petit retour sur la semaine il avant
goût de ce qui s'en vient pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne ici et redit
oh